hi come in I brought you some red dye  you have to make all the end of our  jungle green so I thought you might not  have time to get by Piggly wigglies  right thank you hi it's nice to meet you  Jack nice to meet you please keep your  seat why she's gorgeous  when you see a new one like this it  makes you want to have another yeah the  colonel gave us the rest of the day off  to be with our families you're so  prepared  it was just second nature to me I should  have been ready nobody's ready for her  husband to go to war you just do what we  have to  I love Jack so much but he's supposed to  be here with me  yeah I don't know what to tell you  Father I accept this do you know the  most common thing an American soldier  says but he's dying on the battlefield  tell my wife I love her